okay do we have critical mass
I think some of the principles are still
out outside but wow that was gosh I had
no idea that I could get people to be
quiet it was good I think the doors are
closing and other people will be
straying in so did you make any new
friends to meet some new people while
you were outside good well I'm having a
great time and you know one of the one
of the good parts about being the
moderators that you do get to meet a lot
of people and I just came across some
facets fascinating people I talked with
somebody who's having trouble getting
her transcripts so I'm hoping she's been
connected to the right person I just
want everyone to know I cannot solve
those problems but there are people here
who can I spoke with a wonderful woman
whose son who's actually she said I'm
not a Columbia person when I'm here with
my sister
her son is taking a Kaplan SAT course
this morning and she said as a parent
she learned a lot and you know thinks
this would be a good place for her son
so please apply
we hope that he's studying hard on those
on that test a couple of another
announcement dare inchoate and ken
tamashiro who you know as their
representative here for the Columbia
Club wants to remind all of you
Washington DC residents that there will
be elections and they're looking for
people to violate elections for the club
officers and they're looking for people
to volunteer or to suggest other people
for the Columbia University Club of
Washington DC you can find out more at
sea you see DC org see you see DC org so
please volunteer and please seek out Ken
and Daren do you guys want to stand up
so people will know who you are so those
who are ready to lead in DC can contact
you
now actually I'm gonna make sure that
Linda is okay everybody's perfect great
okay I just wanted to have eyesight of
the people who are coming on before I
bring out our next panelist I just spoke
with someone who said I came for two
reasons and one of them was to hear this
panel so you have you already have an
enthusiastic audience member Scott tatah
can told me that he's the chief
statistician for Genworth Financial
which is the world's largest provider of
long-term care insurance and he knows a
lot wants to connect with other columbia
people who want to talk about these very
important issues so you want to stand up
so people know you
she's statistician at Genworth this is
chose you columbia is leading our is my
pleasure to introduce dane linda freed
who is a leader in the fields of
epidemiology and geriatrics she's been a
dedicated leader in in medicine and
science of healthy aging she's been
named a living legend in medicine by the
US congress and she has been Dean of the
mailman School of Public Health since
2008 we talked a little bit earlier
because I said you know I really hate to
just give that sort of standard resume
thing and as we were talking I was
feeling her enthusiasm for the work
she's doing really just how exciting a
field public health is and how maehlman
is one of the leading as you know public
health schools in the world but one
thing she told me that I found
absolutely fascinating one of her first
initiatives was to create a columbia
public health both inspired by the
Hippocratic oath to give voice to the
aspirations and responsibilities of
public health to society so she's really
making a difference already dean linda
free
Thank You Olivia for that one very
gracious introduction and and thank you
to all of you for being here I deeply
and I think increasingly everyday feel
how critical it is for us to have great
universities that make a great society
and it is the partnership of those who
have been in that great University
ensuring its greatness for the future
that I think our society rests on I'm
very excited given the conversation that
we just had in the prior panel to try
and think about one of the many
important intersections between science
a discussion of the morning and
leadership a discussion in the morning
and I think one of those very important
intersections is rests in public health
as the science a scientific basis of
much of the leadership needed I think in
coming years and today we have three
fabulous alumni who are leaders at that
intersection between science and policy
based on great leadership with the
charge in each of their sectors to
improve the public's health on a local
national and international level and
they truly exemplify I think the
catchphrase of our school which is
science action impact they represent
more over three different sectors now of
the public health Enterprise in a great
society academia government and NGOs
they all trained at one school all with
a common foundation in the science and
evidence of how to improve the public's
health and each with an understanding of
the common responsibilities and
aspirations we have societally and the
different roles that each different
sector must play individually and to get
I'd like to introduce the members of our
panel today with actually great
excitement and then make a few opening
remarks before we turn to our discussion
on protecting the public's health
through effective US and global health
policy with a focus on the challenges
and the leadership needed I'll start
first at the other end of the row with
dr. Raphael Sadr dr. al-sadr
graduated from our School of Public
Health in 1991 with an mph after she had
her MD and she's an internationally
renowned research scientist and
infectious disease physician and global
leader in bringing science public health
and medicine to hiv/aids tuberculosis
tuberculosis other infectious diseases
and in the form of the health systems
that really create health for
particularly vulnerable populations
around the world Zweifel wears several
hats at Columbia she's a professor of
Epidemiology in medicine at the melmans
School in the College of Physicians and
Surgeons she's the director of the
International Center for AIDS program
AIDS care and treatment programs better
known as I cap i cap recently celebrated
a milestone of serving 1 million people
in 15 countries in Africa
Wafaa also leads the Global Health
Initiative at Columbia's maehlman School
and Columbia University's Presidential
Commission on global health she's a
member an elected member of the
Institute of Medicine a recipient of the
MacArthur Genius award and was named
almost simultaneously by Rolling Stone
magazine as one of the top 100 people
who are changing America and at this in
the same week as one of scientific
American's top 10 who were guiding
science for Humanity next to dr. al-sadr
is lecturer Cheryl Hilton Cheryl
received her dr pH in 1991 from the
School of Public Health and she has
dedicated her career to finding
real-world solutions to preventing
smoking and helping people quit smoking
she is the founding CEO of the legacy
foundation where she has guided the
highly acclaimed national youth tobacco
prevention campaign which is called
truth in the past 10 years truth has
prevented almost half a million kids
from smoking Cheryl was for a number of
years the chair of the department of
sociomedical Sciences in our school
public health but she has had many roles
as author researcher professor
administrator with more than 25 years of
experience across all the dimensions of
the public health enterprise she's a
frequent public speaker hears frequently
on Good Morning America The Today Show
and recently on MSNBC's cigarette Wars
Cheryl welcome thank you
and last but certainly not least Julie
Piotrowski Julie received her mph from
our school in 2008 she's a former
journalist who has spent more than a
decade researching analyzing and
reporting public health issues and
developing health promotion and disease
prevention programs she is currently the
speechwriter at the US Department of
Health and Human Services for assistant
secretary for health dr. Howard Koh as a
night public health journalism fellow
prior to that at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention she trained with
the u.s. epidemic intelligence service
and assisted in creating effective
health communication strategies for our
country and for the world
while working before that at the mailman
schools national center for disaster
preparedness Julie developed
bioterrorism and emergency preparedness
programs for the New York City
Department of Health and Mental Hygiene
so we are thrilled to have you here
today and in preparation for this I read
a statement Julie by your boss dr.
Howard Koh who pointed out that in the
US Department of Health and Human
Services report for healthy people 2010
we have to remember that health of the
individual is quote unquote almost
inseparable from health of the larger
community I would add beyond that that
Public Health has been built over the
last 100 plus years from a scientific
base of recognizing that an individual's
health is actually dependent on the
larger community a few examples whether
one is by birth part of a group that
experiences significant vulnerability in
health disparities because of their
place in society whether a child living
with people who smoked or in a family
that is overweight is a greater risk of
becoming a smoker or overweight the
answer is yes
whether nutritious foods are available
is often not the option of the
individual whether people can walk or
play outside safely goes beyond the
individual's ability to control air
pollution or how well we prepare for
earthquakes tsunamis or other exposures
are all issues of how the community the
community's preparation the community's
anticipation the community's response in
knowledgeable ways across all sectors
protects our collective health sixty to
eighty percent of a populations health
is dependent on public health approaches
it's been said that even when public
health works best and when it's working
best we count on it but it is invisible
and it is the disease we didn't get the
accident we didn't have the disaster
that didn't happen and a key challenge
for leaders on something that when
successful is invisible and when
unsuccessful you get blamed for is how
to lead not just to sustain the
successes that we count on for the
present but to anticipate the challenges
ahead of us which are highly complicated
and to both to prepare for them and to
create broad understanding across all
communities about what's in it for all
of us and what role we all have to play
so it turns out that in fact public
health is now recognized as an inter
sectoral responsibility every sector in
society every educated person every
person in society benefits from it and
in fact must understand the problems
ahead and help lead on it as well I
think that the conversation on this in
my experience has changed dramatically
in the last
ten years perhaps because many of the
challenges ahead of us are not invisible
although a recognition of the sector
responsible sometimes may be clearly
discussions at the World Economic Forum
which recently which they had the
privilege of joining president Bollinger
for example if I'd that corporations
government civil society all recognized
as as spoken by Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton that public health
solutions are a key part of all of our
well-being from national security to
actually the diseases we do or do not
wake up with in the morning so with that
background I'd like to turn to the panel
and the topic at hand which is
protecting the public's health through
effective US and global health policy
and not coincidentally as I said we have
both three fabulous alumni who are
leaders in their own right but three
alumni who represent different sectors
not all the sectors but three sectors of
what enables us to protect the public's
health and so I'd like to start out by
asking each of our panelists to comment
on for the sector that they are
currently working in what are its
responsibilities for protecting the
public's health and how does it build on
science and evidence to accomplish that
and I'll start with Julie piotrowski
thank you it's an honor to be here and
this morning in conversation with such a
diverse group of leaders and future
leaders and to learn from the group
while most of you are not public health
professionals as Dean freed said the
work of Public Health affects you every
day and after a few years of covering
health as a journalist I realized that
to do my best work I needed to really
develop an understanding of public
health and that led me to the mailman
School of Public Health where I am very
grateful for the outstanding education
that I received working with so many
leaders across many different sectors to
ultimately promote and protect health
and assure that all people can reach
their highest attainable standard of
Health at mailmen our statement of
values reads and this is applicable to
the field of public health in general
and I quote we are committed to
principles of social justice and to the
promotion of health as a fundamental
right of every human being we aspire to
alleviate human suffering and improve
the health of all populations especially
the most vulnerable through research
service communication and informed
advocacy so this statement or concept
that health is a fundamental right is
really key in this nation we have
differences in terms of wealth we have
people with smaller incomes and we have
millionaires and multimillionaires we
have differences in education from those
with high school level education to
those with multiple advanced degrees we
have differences in employment my
grandmother was a school custodian for
years we have CEOs and folks on the
Forbes you know fortune 500 list and
these are differences that we accept but
we what we do not accept and what we
should not accept our differences in
health or health disparities that is
Dean freed set are linked with social
and economic or environmental
disadvantages and so while medical
advances and new technologies have
provided us with the potential for
longer and healthier lives and better
quality of life we have these
disparities that exist in in the US and
continue to affect multiple groups of
people so differences based on gender
religion sexual orientation race and
ethnic group geographic location or some
other characteristic that's historically
linked with discrimination or exclusion
so where we live and learn and work and
play and pray even in some cases affects
our health and
it is very true that the health of the
individual is inseparable from the
health of the community and so both
government and all of us as a component
of good citizenship have a
responsibility for building healthy
societies and creating the conditions in
which people can be healthy and to do
this we do need as the Dean said health
in all policies approach integrating
health policy efforts with those related
to agriculture business education
housing transportation and other areas
outside of the health sector so one
example from my work is the first lady's
initiative let's move to end childhood
obesity within a generation and there's
a component of this campaign called the
healthy food financing initiative and
this is the program that increases the
availability and affordability of
healthy foods and underserved
neighborhoods so both urban and rural
and it brings grocery stores to what we
call food desert communities so these
are communities and neighborhoods that
don't have access for residents to
affordable healthy foods and to support
this initiative we have a multi sector
partnership between the department's of
Agriculture Health and Human Services
the Department of Treasury and they've
partnered together to make about 400
million dollars and financing to
Community Development and financial
institutions available so that both
these groups and also non-for-profits
and public partners can come together
and look at strategies for bringing
grocery stores into communities so
that's just one example to illustrate
the kind of partnerships that we're
talking about it was with this interest
in creativity and innovation in public
health partnerships and leadership and
in planning that I came to Health and
Human Services a couple years ago and
every day I passed through the lobby of
the Hubert H Humphrey building named for
former senator Hubert Humphrey and
there's a quote that is on the wall that
I look at every day as I go up to my
office
and that quote reads the moral test of
government is how that government treats
those who are in the dawn of life the
children those who are in the twilight
of life the elderly and those who are in
the shadows of life to SiC the needy and
the handicapped so at Health and Human
Services whether it's providing millions
of children and families and seniors
with access to high-quality health care
or exploring new frontiers of biomedical
research and science as the discussions
highlighted this morning it's our
obligation as a department and as a
government working across agencies in
the US and abroad to make investments
where they'll reach the most people
where they will build most effectively
on the efforts of our partners and where
they'll lead to the biggest gains and
health and ultimately opportunity for
all so at the heart of all of our work
what we really strive to do is to create
better systems of prevention to prevent
disease from occurring instead of
treating disease too late despite the
fact that we have an incredible health
care system in this country the best in
the world arguably with doctors and
nurses and other professionals who do
incredible incredible work and I think
for me it's been a privilege to work for
an administration that understands the
power of prevention at all levels in
society at the individual level at the
business level and in communities as
well as at the national level so much
about what we've heard on the
health-care law so far has been focused
on insurance reform but this is the law
that really brings prevention to the
forefront of our national conversation
and I'm happy to detail some of the
prevention provisions later but the most
important thing is that while it's not a
panacea for eliminating all of the
health disparities that we face it's a
great start and we do need the
cooperation and creativity and
innovation of everyone across sectors to
help people truly reach their highest
attainable standard of Health thanks
Julie the policies that you
that was very eloquent and and I think
exemplifies many of the policies on
prevention that we that the government
is implementing and that our deep
actually simply substantively based on
public health science and prevention
science coming out of schools of Public
Health Cheryl I wonder if you could talk
about how that same base of evidence and
knowledge drives the actions of the
Legacy Foundation and similar nonprofit
foundations well thank you I'm delighted
to be here today among the alums in the
Washington area and others my two
favorite alums of all are in the
audience my husband from the School of
Public Health and my daughter from
Columbia College shout-out to you but
let me just start by following on with
with the basic overarching framework and
that is a framework of social justice
and the fact that we just don't have it
we don't have it here in the United
States of America and we most certainly
do not have it around the world and in
terms of the world health definition of
health and absence of disease but also
well-being social well-being we are
probably in many respects moving in the
wrong direction and in a handful moving
in the right direction in in that
overarching picture the NGO community as
it's called globally and the nonprofit
community of which I am a part as it is
known here in the US has an
extraordinarily important role to play
as partners with government as partners
with philanthropy as partners with
basically every individual that wants to
address the key killers in our in our
society which differ of course in the
developed world in other parts of the
world first and foremost the nonprofit
sector needs to be a catalyst it needs
to be the drumbeat it needs to be the
aggravating voice that's demain
that the right thing be done it also
needs to motivate philanthropy the
United States probably donates more
money globally and at both an individual
and governmental in fact it certainly
does than the other than any other
country in the world but we also as
individuals donate more than virtually
any other country in the world and that
is a big piece of the engine that drives
the nonprofit sector which is extremely
broad and well developed in our nation
so let me just turn to tobacco as an
example simply because it is incredibly
unique and I want to point out a few of
the uniquenesses about it because if it
is left unchecked we are looking at a
really extraordinary calamity that will
be facing us let's start with the fact
that tobacco is a global health crisis
it is 100 percent preventable tobacco
related death by simply not using the
product by the close of the century the
World Health Organization has estimated
that 1 billion people will die as a
result of tobacco let me repeat that 1
billion people presently 5 million
people worldwide die every year of
tobacco and in contrast to our
experience in New York or Washington
that somehow the tobacco epidemic is
getting under control the sad global
fact is that it's wildly out of control
and the rate of smoking is rising around
the world wherever there is a vulnerable
population that the tobacco industry can
get its clutches on for example just one
statistic 60% of girls in Santiago Chile
smoked while in our country that number
is is is one-third of that and still
that's a disaster 45 million Americans
still smoke only 5% of the world's
population is covered by Clean Indoor
Air laws and in fact right now assume
there'll be a book coming out of
Colombia Press that legacy underwrote I
think initially made the grant probably
in 2002 and I love the title of the book
it's called after tobacco I go to bed at
night put my head on my pillow
try to imagine after tobacco for me it's
particularly hard because legacy is a
foundation that was created out of
threatened litigation by 46 states
attorneys general against the tobacco
industry and the tobacco industry
settled in lieu of pursuing 46 separate
litigations and a lot of things changed
as a result of that agreement and that
agreement is a model that can be used
globally by law enforcement officials to
institute and generate significant
change and significant public health
protections for individuals what it did
is create the Legacy Foundation among
other things that it did and legacy was
then able to be a counterweight to the
thirteen billion dollars a year that's
13 billion that the tobacco industry
spends marketing its products in the
United States alone which is an enormous
amount of money to put it in some
perspective they spend in a day what
Legacy spends in a year to combat them
they attempted to shut us down we were
in litigation for five and a half years
so an industry that creates a product
that when used as directed kills 50
percent of its users and makes the
enormous profits it makes here in this
world and exports now throughout the
world is one of the principal
ambassadors for our country around the
world is that a situation that we really
want to prevail
well another model of how you can bring
science and public health together has
miraculously happened in this country we
now have food and drug dat over tobacco
and there are many exciting things
happening on that front probably the
most exciting is the release of a report
just a week ago that found that leaving
menthol in cigarettes all other
flavorings were removed in the bill that
went through Congress but leaving
menthol in cigarettes will entice more
young people to smoke and lead to far
fewer people quitting this this report
is being fought you know differently by
the tobacco industry but it's a classic
example where the FDA has empowered a
panel to bring to them the facts and
it's probably for those who have any
interest in the subject worth going to
the FDA website to see the rebuttal that
the tobacco industry put together that
they are vigorously fighting that on a
global scale there is something called
the framework the the WHO Framework
Convention on tobacco control which is a
series of about 16 key recommendations
that every country should implement if
there is any hope to turn the tide on
this tsunami of a billion lives that we
will lose throughout this coming century
virtually every country in the world has
ratified the treaty the treaty has been
a bit of a problem for the US and for
Germany because it it initially
encouraged the cessation of commercial
speech rights with respect to tobacco I
personally favor severing those rights
to me it's no different than saying you
can't jump up and say fire in the
audience if there is no fire in the room
the fact of the matter is that we
protect the right of the tobacco
industry to promote its product and
through the promotion of its product it
manages to a dict millions of people
almost always under the age of 18 at a
time when their brains are not developed
sufficiently to understand the decision
they're making and by the time they
understand it they're addicted so we
have a model in the framework of the WHO
Framework Convention for tobacco control
that could be applied to many many other
problems and the sort of the science
public health call to action for all of
us and for NGOs and nonprofits in
particular is to embrace the Millennium
World Health Organization goals for our
world we are talking about obesity in
the in the United States of America one
in four children are underweight around
the world so we have a dichotomy that's
you sort of wish you to take the food
from one place and put it over the other
place but that's obviously an
oversimplification the Millennium the
Millennium Goals the majority of those
goals which are the goals for the Health
and Social Welfare of the world are in
fact health-related and they
cannot be achieved without the proactive
engagement of the nonprofit sector the
government sectors within countries
intergovernmental agencies individuals
and most especially the social
responsibility of the corporate
community and that is one of the reasons
why I will just close by returning to
the tobacco industry because there if
there ever was an example of an industry
that simply should not exist that is it
you take that and you go through the
continuum of the human health problems
that other industries are capable of
causing and we need to understand that
on the one hand we are partners but on
the other hand we must be regulators as
well so that we can control profits
being put ahead of human health which
happen in every country on the planet
and and that is a very important thing
for us all to collectively address so
thank you for
so we're in part trying to exemplify the
the distinct but complementary roles of
different sectors and contributing to
the public's health and as I said of
course both government and nonprofits
and corporate actions draw heavily on
the science as well as the educational
responsibilities of schools of Public
Health and I'll turn to guava to provide
perhaps some examples of how the actions
and roles of schools of Public Health
lay that foundation thank you very much
Linda and I'm also very thrilled to be
here and to meet graduates of the School
of mailmen as well as other alumni and
especially to be on this panel with
colleagues I guess what I'll start with
is maybe sharing with you
issue one issue that has dominated my
thinking over the past several years
which is this issue over the schism that
exists between knowledge and action and
sometimes I sometimes people have called
it the gap between the know and the do
and others have called it the
responsibility gap and what is the
schism and what is this gap and the
schism is really about what we know the
information we have today and the
knowledge we have today and how that
contrasts with what we've done and what
we're doing in the world and then I'll
circle back and maybe share with you
ways in which I think public health can
really bridge that schism and bridge
that gap and really take on this
responsibility can fill the
responsibilities gap in the world
including of course the United States so
we have a lot of knowledge we have a lot
of information we have a lot of tools in
our hands for example we know how to
create clean water we know how to
diagnose various diseases we know how to
give vaccinations we have remarkable
vaccines we know how to prevent HIV we
know how to treat HIV
you know how to prevent mothers from
dying in childbirth we know how to
resuscitate babies and keep them alive
so we have all this knowledge but then
you look on the other hand when you
contrast the wealth of knowledge we have
today we don't have all the answers we
need a lot more answers but we have a
lot of knowledge in our knowledge bag in
our toolbox and then you contrast what
we know versus the state of global
health and whether that be in the US or
internationally and you can see the
schism that exists and why is there such
such a schism and I think one of the
reason is that we have valued very much
the discovery of knowledge and that's
very important and that's absolutely a
support they need for discovery and you
need for more and more discovery the
discovery of knowledge and I believe we
have not valued as much how do we take
that knowledge into action we assumed
that once a discovery is made that
somehow magically it's going to be
disseminated successfully and it's going
to happen and the world will read the
benefits of that knowledge and the
reality is that that doesn't happen
because there is a science and there are
skills there's information there's a way
there's a the how to actually take the
knowledge into action is a science by
itself that has not and that I believe
has been underappreciated thus far now
there's a long history actually and
thinking back about some of the when
president Bollinger was speaking about
Columbian the history of Columbia
there's a what I was reading about the
history of Columbia at some point in the
1930s a former president of Columbia
president LOH gave a very important
speech that challenged universities at
that point in time and challenged
educators at that point in time to think
they have beyond the walls of
universities and think about how they're
educating students and think of the
responsibilities of a university to
it's community and at that time it was
challenging Colombia to think beyond the
walls of Colombia and think of New York
City in the 1930s and how can the city
inform the education of the students and
how can the city inform the actions of
the University and reflecting on that
and the university today not just come
on Bay but all universities is not only
are we we have to think beyond the walls
of our universities to our immediate
community but now we are global
universities we have to think about the
the walls what what lies behind the wall
of the university not just in our
community in New York City for Columbia
but globally and how what happens in the
world should inform what we do as an
education institution but also how we
prepare our students for the future so
going back to that schism and that
responsibility gap that I mentioned I
think there are ways in which and I
believe quite strongly that public
health has a unique role to play a
unique role in the discovery of new
knowledge but a very unique role in
bridging that schism in actually
bringing knowledge to action in the
science and the study of how do you
disseminate how do you implement how do
you scale up pieces of information
pieces of science tools to have an
impact on the world to have an impact on
our own City and as well as also to have
an impact on the world as a whole and I
think that's where I see the schools
academia in general but I see mailmen in
particular in filling that
responsibility gap and just to reflect a
bit on what we're trying to do at the
moment to bridge that gap and to go from
discovery to action I always think when
I go and visit some of the programs
overseas and I walk to a country office
in LA where I cap works in Ethiopia or
Lesotho or Swaziland and these are very
very poor countries physik huge global
challenges I've always heartened by the
cycle the cycle of discovery and action
and how we actually can close that
circle very effectively when I see our
own teams doing Public Health in action
they're innovating they're learning by
doing and they're taking what they're
learning they're learning from what
they're doing but they're also
discovering by doing and then they take
these innovations and they take them
back right into the field to the science
of action and then they bring it back
again to discovery and innovation and
it's it's quite interesting when you see
this very dynamic process happening on
the ground we've always assumed that it
has to happen somehow in our own
backyard
or in our own academic institutions but
we can also nurture this kind of
discovery as well as this kind of action
and the closing of the circle between
the discovery and the action we can
nurture that to happen all around the
world by just always thinking of that
schism and always trying to bridge that
schism and try to think of the ways in
which our knowledge and the tools we
have today can advance global health so
I feel very privileged actually in
thinking about the potential for Public
Health and the potential for the
University in this point in history as a
catalyst for generating knowledge and
science but also as a catalyst for
taking that into action through very
rigorous scientific endeavor and I think
it's by doing this that we can actually
change the world
bit by bit but we can take on and be the
leaders in closing this responsibility
gap thank you
each of you are confronted in those
spheres you're in with responsible with
both responsibility and knowledge of a
responsibility gap that you have to
close at at different levels in terms of
individuals where you're seeking to do
prevention and provide better care in
communities for countries the frame that
Julie was talking in and globally and
we're confronted with the need to link
science and policy in in particular in
the face of highly complex issues where
perhaps the solutions exists at levels
where we didn't look for them before
Sheryl started by talking about treaties
for example and I was wondering if you
could comment on some models of
governance that that we need to reach
for that would best implement government
governance or systems that would best
implement for the sake of the public's
health the knowledge that we have but
we're not using Sheryl could you could
you maybe go back to the global health
treaty example on tobacco which as as
you suggested is is novel and what its
implications might be there well the
implications are profound in the sense
that there are many articles related to
this treaty and it took literally years
to negotiate and the negotiations were a
combination of policy science and
government and business leaders from
around the globe and the the the treaty
itself calls upon nations to implement
price and tax measures to reduce the
demand of tobacco it calls upon them to
protect individuals from exposure to
secondhand smoke which kills 600
600,000 people worldwide each year to
regulate the contents of tobacco
products which I was alluding to earlier
in the case of menthol which will be a
battle royal in this country to change
the packaging the you may find it
interesting that tobacco pack of
cigarettes in Taiwan 50% of the pack is
covered with a warning label and has
been for years and we ship cigarettes
with that warning label out of our
country and we do the same from our
country into Canada but we still do not
have anything that could be legitimately
called
an effective warning label but we do now
thanks to the FDA it also regulates it
also calls upon nations to regulate
tobacco advertising most especially
advertising that reaches children and
product placement in television and film
which has been one of the most
controversial components of it from the
tobacco industry's perspective because
for years they've spent millions and
millions and millions of dollars to get
people to smoke at movies Christopher
Reeve smoked Marlboros in Superman in
exchange for 1.5 million dollars as just
one example and also the the the
articles call upon the countries to
treat addiction and one of the wonderful
elements in the new health reform bill
in our nation is that we will now be
calling upon all health plans to treat
addiction which has not been the case we
still need to do a little more work in
terms of Medicaid the the program for
the poor so this type of a model has put
into action in virtually every country
in the world activities related to this
the first Health Treaty in the history
of the world we've had many many
treaties but we've not had one that was
focused on health so it's a very viable
model and one that I think should be
replicated as do I believe the model of
the MSA can and ought to be replicated
in nations where
consumer protection falls within a legal
framework that allows the equivalent of
our attorneys general in other countries
to intercede on behalf of the public and
protect them through through laws and
through throughout of litigation and the
like so we have the tools in our toolkit
we need to use them aggressively and I
think at the end of the day there is no
as Wafaa just pointed out so eloquently
there there are very few health problems
that exist in the world today that we
don't have the solution for in science
in medicine it's called you know from
the bench to the bedside
we are not doing the bench to the
bedside on the public health framework
as well as we might simply because we
are we are unable to mobilize the forces
and a lot of it I think has to do with
with political stability in countries
with the legitimacy of the leadership of
the countries and a lot of it sadly has
to do with our own mobilisation of
infrastructure
Linda you said what was the one thing we
could do you know we have health reform
but the overwhelming majority of
physicians and the vast majority of
public health professionals in the US
and worldwide believe that the quickest
way to improve the health of our country
is a single-payer system everyone has a
ticket to the ballgame so to speak and
we are not wasting huge amounts of money
and diversions we didn't get that we got
something halfway there and I'll take
half a loaf before I'll take no loaf any
day of the week and for a variety of
political reasons of what a lot of
people knew was the best thing to do
simply could not happen what we have is
good my hope is that we can get good to
be good to great thank you
so before I'm gonna cue the audience
they say we're going to move to a
question and answer session in just a
moment so while you're thinking about
your idea of your questions or your
answers
I'll give the last question to Julie
Cheryl has done her usual elegant job as
has Wafaa in in laying out the
dimensions of what public health
scientists and professionals would call
a multi sector and multi-level approach
at every level of society so that
everybody's doing their part to
accomplish the public's health whether
it's labeling on packages or grocery
stores in cities that have none those
are actually public health interventions
can you tell us Julie why what
difference investing in prevention makes
in terms of populations health sure well
I'm glad that Cheryl use the word
mobilization that is part of the new
mission statement of our office at the
office of the assistant secretary for
health formerly the office of public
health and science just had a name
change and our mission statement is
mobilizing leadership in science and
prevention for a healthier nation so
obviously all of us at some point in our
lives will be affected by a health issue
or families will or our friends and you
know health is a gift and we don't want
to be treating disease after the fact if
we don't have to despite our incredible
health system and the people who work in
it to save lives every day we want to be
able to bring down costs we want to be
able to work both at the individual
level and at the community level to
prevent disease promote health and
ensure that people can enjoy their life
I mean health is you know a beautiful
gift so
why why suffer if we don't need to so
the Affordable Care Act is just one
component of prevention that is really
focused on expanding access to care
bringing down cost and also improving
healthcare quality and so when we think
about prevention we also think about
preventing healthcare-associated
infections and hospitals we think about
prevention as far as medical errors and
there are so many components of this law
that emphasize prevention throughout the
healthcare system to bring down costs
but ultimately to improve quality for
patients and to improve quality of life
and to ensure that people get the care
that they need when they need it and as
I mentioned earlier much of the
conversation at the national level about
this law has been focused on the
respective insurance provisions that
will afford people more access but what
we really haven't talked about as a
nation is the expansive unprecedented
investment in prevention at every level
and so that means for example at the
individual level you now will be able to
go to your doctor and without paying a
co-payment receive clinical preventive
services so assistance with smoking
cessation assistance with counseling for
nutrition and the supplies to children
as well as adults if you are an older
person in Medicare you will be able to
receive a health and wellness visit
you'll work with your doctor to put
together a wellness plan and this of
course is going to cost time you know
for physicians to learn how to you know
devote more time to these kinds of
conversations with patients but the key
is that they will be reimbursed and so
we're changing through healthcare reform
our payment models so that were giving
incentives for physicians to implement
prevention in the clinical visit at the
business level we have all sorts of
provisions in this law to ensure the
expansion of
employee wellness programs we have new
federal initiatives that we'll be
looking at providing businesses with
assistance for their workplace wellness
programs technical assistance at the
community level we have community
transformation grants millions and
millions of dollars that are invested in
tobacco cessation in obesity prevention
and ensuring that the models that we're
putting into place are effective that
they're evidence-based that they've been
proven to be effective and then that
we're scaling them up in a way that is
meaningful for those communities but
also ensuring that we give communities
some flexibility to based on their own
unique challenges and populations sort
of fine-tune the keys of those of those
programs for change and use them to
ultimately improve health two really big
components of the health care law that
are very exciting as far as prevention
are at the national level we have a new
public health fund that over the next
ten years has appropriations of almost
fifteen billion dollars in mandatory
spending for public health programs this
is a huge success for the for the public
health folks but you know ultimately we
need leadership and mobilization of
leadership to support the replication of
these programs so to implement this
funding in a way that is really
meaningful and we've already released
about five hundred million in fiscal
2010 and we'll release another 750
million soon in 2011 and the president's
2012 budget includes just an
unprecedented amount of funding for
prevention as well we also have a new
Council for Health Promotion and disease
prevention this is the national level
sort of kitchen cabinet as I like to say
of folks who are invested in models that
work and we'll be releasing a health
promotion and disease prevention
strategy for the nation so this is a
partnership between federal agencies and
leaders and private sector leaders and
so again just returning to the theme of
taking what we know applying it
way that has been proven effective and
allowing some flexibility for how we
make these programs work at the
community level and for those of you who
are interested in what our health goals
are as a nation you can go to
healthypeople.gov which is the federal
government sort of roadmap for for
change and we have 42 different topic
areas everything from LGBT health which
is a new topic area this year to tobacco
cessation healthcare access and quality
maternal and child health we have our
baseline of where we are at now with the
percentage of the population that is
affected by the particular health issue
and then our target for 2020 we release
healthy people goals every 10 years so
this is just a tremendously rewarding
time to be working in public health not
just as a public health leader in the
sector of public health but for all of
us we know what the goals are healthy
people also has a section for the
interventions that work so I encourage
any of you for the topic of your
interest to go on to that side and look
and see where we are where we're headed
and to think about how you can make an
impact in your organization to get to a
place where you have a healthier nation
Thank You Julie that was great
these are three of our fabulous alums
but you're the you're also our fabulous
alums and we'd like to hear from you
hopefully to having teed up the
beginnings of a broader conversation on
all sector thoughts on fostering the
public's health I'll start over there
yes hi I'm Laura Kelly I'm a student at
the School of Public Health dr. Elson ER
I was wondering if you could talk about
what what do you think are some ways to
improve the implementation science issue
in public health you discussed thank you
I think it's a very important question
and maybe we'll decide what is the
implementation science I think the I
would traditionally where people are
thought of research that sort of basic
research or clinical research
I haven't really thought about what's
called implementation research or
implementation science and
implementation science gets it exactly
that gap that I was talking about which
is the hell of taking knowledge to how
you assess implementation of
implementation of programs and really
evaluate them appropriately and learn
from them in order to be able to scale
them up there are many different things
that should be done one is clearly to
entice young people students faculty to
be interested in this kind of endeavor
as I mentioned earlier this is a new
scholarly endeavor that's kind of a
little bit alien to the usual generation
of knowledge framework it is generation
of knowledge but is rather alien to the
traditional generation of knowledge
frameworks I think getting faculty
getting researchers getting students to
be very to be attuned to what this means
and to be excited at doing the kind of
research that would address some of
these very important key issues in terms
of global health
I think another is to actually support
this kind of research of this kind of
science it's again it's not one of the
little needs funding from funders
whether it be by foundations or by CDC
or USAID or NIH for example of this kind
of endeavor of how a technology into
action is very important and there's a
huge gap and funding for this kind of
work as well and I think lastly of
course is that too for us as a as a
scholarly community is to be at the
forefront of trying to generate this
kind of information through this kind of
work thank you the other microphone hi
I'm Scott catechin Columbia College 1987
and I've heard a lot of talk about
prevention I've heard a lot of talk
about smoking cessation or childhood
obesity and I'm concerned about a
problem that may not be entirely
preventable
a period of disability in the very
latest years of life and I wondered what
whether public health professionals
think about this period and the
tremendous impact that it's going to
have fiscally and also societally on the
developed world having so many aged
people and so few people to take care of
them I think that one has my name all
over it I couldn't take it if anybody
wants to add something one of the really
remarkable things is that we're going
through a demographic revolution I would
say that the success of public health in
the main supported by great medicine and
medical cares that we've almost doubled
life expectancy in the last hundred
years pretty fabulous that was our goal
and people are getting to live much
longer lives but there are high risk
particularly as people develop what we
only call non communicable chronic
diseases that rates of disability are
high in association with that one of the
necessities of course in a compassionate
society is to support going back to the
quote that Julie gave us at the very
beginning is to support the most
vulnerable parts of society and meet
their needs and support autonomy of
people even when they're disabled as
much as possible and certainly in an
aging society it's critical that we do
that but remarkably a significant
proportion of disabilities are
associated with aging are preventable
and there's good evidence now that
they're preventable both by preventing
the chronic diseases that cause them
they're preventable by taking approaches
actually in the face of early disability
to ameliorate it and they are modifiable
by providing supportive environments
that permit people to compensate in one
way or another for their disabilities so
we know a lot now we don't know
everything we need to know but I think
we know a lot now about how to improve
people's function and ability to remain
engaged in the world into the oldest
stages some of and we need a mixed
portfolio if you will of prevention care
and supportive services to accomplish
that hopefully while improving the
health with which people age thank you
go back over here yes hi now you
mentioned that public health got a good
boost in the bill but on state and local
levels it's getting battered in good
part because it's tarred with the brush
of the nanny state what are each of you
if you just go through what are you
doing to separate even to the more
conservative of our brothers and sisters
who are out there to separate to say
though this is not a liberal or
conservative issue this is simply about
getting information out on good sense
Julie I you know I think the first thing
I would say about the importance of this
law is that we have you know close to 50
million people in this country who don't
have a regular access to care ability to
see a physician regularly and so this is
only one component of the larger
challenged prevention and I think we
need to have the access issue dealt with
when you have 16 to 17 percent of the
population that is not able to get care
you know you're not able to have your
public health programs work as
effectively if you're meeting these
individuals at stages where their
disease
advanced so it's important that we get
these folks into the system as Cheryl
said it's not a perfect law but it is a
good first step and I think we have to
make these investments now as as much as
they will cost now they will cost us far
more later if we don't invest now
ensuring that people get into the system
that we bring down costs and that we
ultimately improve quality and that's
just not quality in the health care
system but also quality in the public
health system and so one of the
conversations that we're having now at
the state level is what is the role of
public health and ensuring quality and
so we have these two sort of separate
quality conversations happening at the
same time ultimately we're hoping to
bring down costs but I think we won't
see some of that initially that'll sort
of come in stages and I'm not sure what
the alternative is I mean to leave that
percentage of the population without
care
it just doesn't bode well for us and
certainly from a competitive standpoint
as well I mean if you're a business and
you're hiring employees you want them to
be healthy you don't want to be
absorbing those costs in the future so I
think it's something that we have a
moral obligation to do and how we sort
of fine-tune those components and what
that looks like in States is an evolving
challenge and conversation and so we're
trying to give states and flexibility to
implement the law given the challenges
that they have thank you I've got I just
saw the sign that says that we have four
more minutes to this session so I'm
gonna do my best to get through
everybody who's at the mic sit but if
everyone can be brief well we might we
have a prayer or getting there go ahead
I'm Beth Belushi I'm a graduate 97
graduate of both the College of
Physicians and Surgeons and the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences and one of
the things that I've noticed as a
physician is that in medical school we
weren't really you didn't talk much
about what health means we mostly had
this sort of unstated concept that what
health means is no
disease and what I've noticed after
treating patients now for some time is
that we really focus on this idea of
health as no disease as the absence of
disease and even in some ways as some
sort of perfection like we don't even
age would be health and I'm becoming
more and more convinced that to live
healthy lives both as individuals and as
a society we need to start thinking
about health as sometimes living with
disease sometimes living with aging
which we all have to do and also living
with dying and that we need to sort of
return to a way of thinking about health
as not eradicating or fixing things
necessarily although that's a part of it
but also how to incorporate living
healthily with whatever state were in
and I was wondering from the public
health standpoint whether you have a
definition of health or whether that's
sort of part of the ongoing discussion
you said that so eloquently that I'm not
sure the rest of us can add without
detracting but does anyone want to add
to that and I can add a word or two I do
agree with you I think we've narrowly
defined prevention I believe as people
define prevention and we sort of
calculus thought of Public Health as
prevention of disease and and
unfortunately we know that some people
will get some disease because we don't
have solutions we don't have 100%
prevention interventions so we need to
broaden I believe we should broaden the
definition of public health it's it's
really prevention this is but it's also
really prevention of disability and
morbidity mortality from disease and I
think you can see that very graphically
when you look at for example diabetes
certainly we can try to prevent diabetes
but also when you look at the outcome of
someone who has diabetes who has access
to healthcare versus someone from a
developing country who has nothing you
will see that their outcome is very
and these disparities exists within our
own society so I think that we're only
broad and I believe that public health
needs to be much broader than just total
prevention as we has it has been
traditionally conceptualized to also
prevention of disability as well as
ability or disability as well and that's
why I think really this is a great
moment for Public Health because it's it
has such a broad platform working at an
individual level but working at a
population level both hand-in-hand thank
you
dr. Herbert I'm John Herbert my question
is do you think the American people are
willing to pay for the application of
the knowledge that we've gained disease
disease I think we're already in health
care and even with the new bill which is
a great step in the right direction it's
going to cost us more money do you think
society is willing to make the
sacrifices necessary to pay everybody
here it's probably been to McDonald's
but are we willing to make the rest of
them sacrifices so I'm gonna take that
one and say that there are two thoughts
first of all the trust for America's
Health reported last year on analyses
that have been much needed that show
that there is a six-fold return on
investment for prevention of the vast
breadth that we've been talking about
and the timeframe on that is not 50
years it's three years to six years and
ongoing investment yields ongoing return
on investment so we're not talking about
somewhere in the 22nd century that we
would see the benefits I think the
ultimate answer to your question depends
on the people in this room
and it depends on leadership and the
ability to help people set their sights
on who we want to be thank you yes I'm
Robert Wilbur I've been active in the
United Nations Association in looking at
progress or lack of it toward the
Millennium Development Goals I get the
unfortunate conclusion that efforts will
go back to the gap between knowledge
implementation that progress is being
overwhelmed at least in Africa by
population growth and so my commission
would be to what extent is population
growth which you haven't mentioned today
a factor in your thinking in academia
about global health issues there's so
many things we haven't mentioned today
but I'm gonna turn to Wofford to see if
you want to respond well I think I agree
with you that in terms of the Millennium
Development Goals there it's probably
clear that many of the most severely
affected countries not going to reach
their goals it doesn't mean that hasn't
been progress and that's kind of
unfortunate is that there's been
tremendous progress that's been achieved
already and especially when you go
region by region and country specific
country by country so I think we should
really applaud the progress because I
think it ends up being a bit
demoralizing for countries that have
really tried very hard there's been
progress in maternal mortality there's
been progress in under-five mortality
substantial progress it's in progress
obviously in HIV tuberculosis so I think
we're seeing these curves learn
improving over time and and actually
going back to an improvement in life
expectancy in some of the most severely
affected countries nonetheless I think
there are many reasons why countries
cannot reach in some countries will not
reach one or the other of the Millennium
Development Coast could be the resources
could the war civil strife it could be
governance within the country itself and
population growth is one aspect of of
that whole effort but there have also
been remarkable advances as well in
terms of population growth there are
many many countries where we're seeing
the fertility rates go down
we know that with educating women that's
very important aspect of decreasing
fertility is by women being educated
there remains a huge gap in terms of
access to contraceptive methods in some
countries so I think it's one component
it it it is one of the issues that many
countries are tackling and I was clearly
in some of the countries where we work
Family Planning is at the top of the
agenda in the context of all the many
many other health threats and challenges
that some of these countries are facing
thank you
I have to ask the timekeepers can we do
we have time to take the remaining
questions no well I this one's out of my
control but we are happy to talk to any
of you afterwards who have questions and
with such an excited group to continue
the discussion thank you all so much to
our panelists thank you
and now it's my honor and pleasure to
reintroduce president Lee Bollinger